Поточний стан економіки в Україні вже дозволяє
відмовитися від кредитів міжнародних фінансових організацій,
заявив президент Петро Порошенко.
DW поцікавилася,
чи дійсно Україна готова відмовитися від кредитів?
Українська економіка відновилася після кризи,
проте все ще залишається доволі вразливою.
Тому припинення співробітництва з міжнародними
фінансовими інституціями для Києва навряд чи можливе
у короткостроковій перспективі, зазначають економісти.
Цьому є кілька причин, одна з яких -
потреба фінансувати дефіцит державного бюджету,
який на кінець цього року складе 4 мільярди доларів
за оцінками економістів Міжнародного фонду Блейзера,
враховуючи дефіцити місцевих бюджетів.
Втім, навіть якби Україні не треба було
фінансувати дефіцит бюджету, за нею залишається
обов’язок  погашення зовнішнього боргу.
Про цей факт у своєму виступі згадував
і сам Порошенко, вказуючи, що левова частина
кредитів іде саме на повернення попередніх боргів.
Обсяг золотовалютних резервів в Україні,
за рахунок яких відбувається погашення
зовнішнього боргу,  залишається доволі низьким.
Натепер це близько 18 млрд доларів.
Змінити ситуацію можна за рахунок
міжнародних запозичень. На поповнення
золотовалютних резервів спрямовується
частина коштів, запозичених
у Міжнародного валютного фонду.
Наступний рік для країни - рік великих виплат за боргами.
Лише державних зовнішніх боргів Україна
має сплатити близько 6 млрд доларів,
тоді як загалом потреба держави у валюті у 2019-му
може коливатися в межах 8 мільярдів.
Тож без серйозних вливань валюти
тримати ситуацію контрольованою буде вкрай непросто,
вказує економіст Олег Устенко.
Іще одна причина продовження співробітництва
з міжнародними донорами і вливань валюти
в країну - те, що наступного року в Україні
мають пройти два раунди виборів:
президентські та парламентські, що автоматично
передбачає певну політичну невизначеність.
Представники  української влади абсолютно не зацікавлені
у серйозній дестабілізації в країні
напередодні виборів, відповідно і навряд чи
відмовлятимуться від міжнародних запозичень,
зазначають оглядачі. І наголошують:
на ринки боргових зобов’язань нині виходять
багато країн, зокрема США та інші розвинуті держави.
І питання тут полягає не в тому,
чи варто брати гроші в кредит,  а як ефективно їх використати.
У разі ж припинення співробітництва
з міжнародними фінансовими інституціями
й відсутності нових кредитів, як прогнозують фахівці,
на країну чекає девальвація з паралельним
збільшенням рівня інфляції, зменшенням
незалежності Національного банку,
втратою довіри до перспективи розвитку
української економіки й можливості обслуговування
своїх боргів. Усе це може призвести не лише
до вкрай негативних економічних наслідків, але й
до зростання рівня соціальної напруги.
Утім, економісти допускають і оптимістичний сценарій,
за якого Україна ухвалює бюджет без дефіциту,
або ж в ідеалі - з профіцитом. Для цього
витрати мають бути оптимізовані, а доходи - збільшені.
У короткостроковій перспективі це можна зробити
лише за рахунок різкого поліпшення бізнес-клімату
в країні й суттєвого припливу прямих іноземних інвестицій.
Але для цього влада має зробити за півроку-рік більше,
ніж було зроблено за останні чотири роки, що малоймовірно.
Висновок
Припинити співробітництво з міжнародними кредиторами
і просто зараз відмовитися від зовнішніх запозичень
Україна не може. Щоб це стало можливим, країна
має провести реформи, аби забезпечити
приплив прямих іноземних інвестицій.
А отримати кошти на це держава може
саме від міжнародних фінансових організацій.